place à votre page était à présent ce
soir on retrouve bérénice du failli en
direct de la collégiale saint-pierre du
pus ailier la plus ancienne église
d'orléans
bonsoir bérénice ce soir vous nous
présenter une exposition coup de coeur
et oui c'est mon coup de coeur pauline
et vous allez comprendre pourquoi
charles de meaux est une artiste peintre
atypique
vous rendez vous compte sans scrupules
elle s'attaque aux grands classiques
sans scrupules elle ce pas bref c'est
une artiste doté d'une énergie et d'un
talent incroyable
charlotte de maupeou n'a pas peur de
déplaire ni même de renvoyer une image
d'elle parfois peu flatteuse ces
autoportraits sont en quelque sorte la
manière dont elle se voit à un moment
donné de sa vie
l'autoportrait toute façon c'est un face
à face avec soi même et parfois c'est
difficile de se faire des cadeaux enfin
voilà et le moment on s'enferme dans son
atelier pour se retrouver tout seul avec
soi-même c'est quand même des moments
compliqués de la vie j'avoue
elle n'a pas peur de déplaire et elle
n'a pas peur de s'attaquer aux grands
classiques manet courbet de las cases ou
encore vermeer avec la fameuse laitières
et parce qu'elle n'a jamais rompu avec
l'enfance elle travaille au sol
[Musique]
et quand on est au sol on n'a pas du
tout la même appréhension le show
wallemme fait complètement paniqué alors
qu'au sol on dansa va effrayer on bouge
on peut tout d'un coup le tableau se
rétrécit énormément
[Musique]
c'est complètement rock and roll vous
venez de filmer la laitière sur lesquels
elle a marché
les traces de pas dessus ce à la fois
hier est irrévérencieux et respectueux
parce que s'il respectait pas ces
peintres là elle n'aurait pas les aurais
pas réinventer et en même temps elle est
culotté quoi leave a response pas de
questions je marche sur ma toile si je
veux je la froisse eux si je veux je
découpe mes papiers si je veux derrière
olympia je l'enlève le visage si je veux
c'est la femme noire convoi je lui
découvre le sexe si j'en ai envie donc
il ya cette dimension aussi de quasiment
féministe culotté féministe mais aussi
très sage avec ses paysages cabanes de
pêcheurs et grandes fleurs ses
respirations probablement bonsoir
charlotte de maupeou bonsoir alors d'où
vous vient cette énergie incroyable
c'est pas je pense depuis toujours j'ai
toujours dessiné ça a toujours été mon
rapport au monde et le ma manière d'être
voilà alors on l'a vu dans le reportage
vous attaquer au grand peintre voulait
revisité vous êtes culotté quand même
qu'est-ce qui vous ont fait ils m'ont
fait aimer la peinture et ils m'ont
sauvé un peu et ils m'ont donné envie de
peindre
surtout et c'est toujours en regardant
la peinture ou des quand je retourne au
musée ça me recharge les batteries et
j'ai envie de peindre c'est la peinture
qui me donne envie de vous vous dites
pas c'est quand même un petit peu
irrespectueux parce que public il peut
être dérangé par ça oui oui c'est pas
voulu c'est dans ma manière de faire je
pense que c'est pas pour c'est pas pour
provoquer le public c'est moi mon
rapport au tableau que j'ai envie de
montrer mais qui passe par par mois et
la peinture est violente
alors l'autre chose qui captent le
regard ce sont les autoportraits alors
moi je trouve absolument géniaux parce
que vous ne vous mettez pas en valeur
vous osez quoi c c'est fou quoi on vous
voit en petite culotte dans l'atelier
oui en fait j'ai fait poser beaucoup
d'amis ou de j'ai travaillé sur le sujet
des femmes peintres et des femmes
artistes
et puis à un moment j'ai je me suis dit
et pourquoi pas s'attaquer à moi au
sujet propre sujet et voilà c'était moi
et mon chien dans l'atelier qui est un
sujet voilà sur l'intime d'un art
question il ya une personne tout à
l'heure qui vous interpellé qui vous a
dit votre expo la de la moelle ça fait
du bien ça fait plaisir oui ça fait très
plaisir ça fait très plaisir parce que
l'accrochage qu'on a et la mise en scène
des commissaires gilb stieg et ludovic
bureau sebourg hausse est vraiment ils
ont réussi je pense à montrer tout mon
univers
tout le monde l'a aussi bien des dessins
de chiens que des dessins érotiques que
des grandes peintures que décollage
voilà je pense que ce qui intéresse les
gens c'est que tout d'un coup on voit un
univers d'une femme artiste
merci beaucoup et je rappelle que
l'exposition est visible jusqu'au 26
août à la collégiale bien sûr